[Music]
not only does it look like
jenny from the block and ben affleck are
back on
they're also bringing back that old
school pda
too i'm thrilled a source tells et the
two
shared a smooch while working out
together in miami on monday
the two walked into anatomy fitness
separately but according to et's source
they weren't trying to hide their
affection for each other once they were
inside
quote they went to do their workouts
with separate trainers but were
not trying to hide their relationship by
any means
they stayed close to each other while
working out and were hugging
being playful together and shared a kiss
in between
sets it was clear to everyone that they
have
intense chemistry and we're having fun
together you know i can't stop smiling
according to the source ben and jen
looked like two people who are quote
super comfortable and familiar with each
other and who are in the honeymoon phase
and in love the source adds quote they
were having a good time
jennifer works out every day and it's
part of her routine and it seemed like
ben
really wanted to be there too with her i
love it the two
famously known as benifer recently
rekindled their romance 17 years
after their split in 2004. ben has been
spotted visiting
jen's la home on multiple occasions
recently
and the two even took a trip to montana
with a source telling et
they are quote having fun together
adding jen
is loving the attention she has been
getting from ben jen and ben didn't get
along at the end of their relationship
years ago but once their hurt feeling
subsided
they were friendly for many years now
that they've fully reconnected
they are having fun together and care
about each other a great deal
this is a thrill the two first started
dating back in 2002 while starring in
their first movie together julie
i'm sorry do we know each other not yet
they quickly got engaged but by 2003
they called off their wedding just days
before their planned september ceremony
and they officially split in january
2004.
it was my first like adult heartbreak we
were about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know it was like
a tough one for me of course jayla went
on to marry mark anthony whom she shares
13 year old twins
max and emmy with but they split in 2014
after 10 years of marriage
and in 2019 she got engaged to former
mlb star alex rodriguez after
two years of dating but they called off
their engagement in april
she's really funny and amazing and
she's just magical she you know she
everything she touches is just
i've learned so much from her in such a
short period of time now
not only are jlo and ben bringing back
the pda the oscar winner is bringing
back
a sentimental gift jen once famously
gave him
on sunday the two were spotted together
in miami and he appeared to be wearing
the same watch jen gifted him in her
2002 music video
jenny from the block
[Music]
yeah so that's been sporting the watch
back when the two first were together
and that's ben appearing to rock the
same time piece on sunday
so i guess you could say ben and jen's
romance is timeless